Voiceover: So we've talked
about Benjamin Franklin
as a public leader, we've talked about him
as a businessman, we've
talked about him as
an inventor and scientist, now I think the
last piece of the Benjamin Franklin puzzle
is just him as, for lack of a better word,
him as founding father.
Voiceover: Yes, and as a
diplomat in particular,
'cause he was America's first diplomat.
In about 1757, he becomes
the ambassador, or agent,
of the Pennsylvania colony,
to represent Pennsylvania
in London, with the
ministers, to try to make sure
that the rights of the
assembly, and the people
of Pennsylvania, were taken into account.
And eventually, off and on over the next
17 or 18 years, he
becomes an agent for a lot
of the colonies, and starts
representing the interests
of the American colonies in London.
Voiceover: And this is
a really important time
in American history, because this is when
tensions between the U.S.,
between the colonies,
and Great Britain are
really coming to a head.
You have the French and
Indian War really kind of
part of a larger European
war, but that ends
in 1763, the British want
the colonies to pay for it...
Voiceover: Right, that's
the big deal, which is the
British think that the American colonies
have to pay because Britain helped protect
them in the French and
Indian War, and they
just start putting taxes
on the American colonies,
and the American colonies
by this point are as
sophisticated, and as strong
of an economy, as Britain.
They don't feel that they
should be dictated to
by the people in London.
And they have their own
legislatures in each
of the colonies, so they're saying, yeah,
we know we have to have taxes, but our
legislatures should do the taxes.
We don't want taxation
without representation,
as became the rallying
cry, and so it was up to
Franklin to try to talk
the British Parliament
out of things like the
Stamp Act, where every
time you bought a piece
of paper or newspaper
you had to pay a tax to
London, and to give the
power to the colonial legislatures.
Voiceover: So he was really,
you know when we read
in the history books,
this whole time period
of things coming, the
tensions rising, it was
really Benjamin Franklin
that was trying to
negotiate, communicate,
the anger, really...
Voiceover: And he was
very close to a lot of the
people in London then, it was part of the
Enlightenment, there's a wonderful picture
of him there in London, in
which there's Issac Newton
looking over his shoulder,
and so he is part of that
intellectual class of like Doctor Johnson,
and all the people in
London, but unfortunately
the government is still
run by a very aristocratic
Tory elite, and Franklin
has trouble convincing
them to give rights to
the American colonies.
Voiceover: And this breaking up, it does
kind of pain him, because as you mention,
this is the Enlightenment.
Benjamin Franklin is a,
kind of a key figure,
Voiceover: And he obtained electricity,
he was a great scientist, so this is this
great man living in a
small house in London,
right near the Parliament,
and he's very well
respected by all the
intellectuals, but he gets
treated very badly by the Parliament.
At one point he's called
in front of what's called
the Cockpit, which is
a part of Parliament,
and he is humiliated,
because they make fun of him
for trying to stop the
Parliament from taxing
the colonies and that
enrages Benjamin Franklin,
and that finally tips
him over to being closer
to the side of, we may
have to have a revolution
and just break away from England.
Voiceover: And that actually leads to
family problems, 'cause his son...
Voiceover: Yeah, so he
brought his illegitimate son
William over with him, and he's very close
to William, but William
becomes quite aristocratic,
despite the fact, or
maybe because of the fact
that he was illegitimate
kid of a middle-class
person, he starts hanging around with the
dukes and the earls, and he ends up being
appointed by the crown,
basically the government
and the king, to be the royal governor of
New Jersey, so William Franklin becomes a
dedicated loyalist, to
the crown of England, just
as his father Benjamin
Franklin is becoming a rebel,
and siding with those
who want a revolution.
Voiceover: And so everything eventually,
we know how history went, the 1775, 1776,
hostilities begin, 1775
Franklin goes back.
Voiceover: Franklin
goes back, he goes back
unsuccessful because he had tried to stop
the hostilities.
He gets back to Philadelphia once again,
at Market Street he comes off the boat,
and everybody in Philadelphia is kind of
wondering, is he loyal
to the British empire
and the crown, or has he
truly joined the cause
of revolution, and he has
a meeting with his son,
who's then the royal
governor of New Jersey,
and he tells his son he's gonna become
a revolutionary, his
son says I'm gonna stay
loyal to the crown, they
basically barely speak
to each other again for
the rest of their lives,
this is a great break,
and Franklin announces
to the people in Philadelphia,
that he is going to join
the cause of American independence.
And that's when he gets to work with
Jefferson and Adams on the
Declaration of Independence
in July of 1776.
And right after that, in
order to make the Declaration
a reality, they realize
we have to get France
in on our side of the war.
You mentioned that the
French and Indian War,
that the British and the
French had been fighting
for a century almost, off
and on, so in order for the
U. S. to win its
independence in a war against
Britain, it would help to
have the support of the
French, who are naturally
willing to fight Britain,
(chuckling) given any
opportunity, and were already
part of a larger global war with Britain.
So he becomes ambassador in Paris,
in order to get the French in.
Now if you look at
those two pictures, it's
kind of cool, 'cause
there's Franklin in London,
looking like quite a
gentleman in a velvet coat.
When he gets to France, he
realizes that the French
people have been reading
Jean Jacques Rousseau,
maybe once too often,
about all the natural man
and the forest, and how
the natural philosopher
comes from the back woods.
Franklin never lived in
the back woods, (chuckling)
he lived in Boston,
Philadelphia, and London
his whole life, but when he gets to Paris,
he wears a coonskin cap, and sort of a
backwoodsman coat, so that he can appear
to the French as sort of this wilderness
natural man philosopher from the forest,
talking about independence and liberty.
Voiceover: And that's what
he did, I mean he does
eventually return, but
he's in Paris, he does
convince the French...
Voiceover: to get in on our
side of the war Voiceover:
to get on our side of the war
And he spends a significant amount of
time there, and becomes...
Voiceover: Oh, he becomes a grand old man
in Paris, first of all as a diplomat
convincing the French
to come in on our side
of the war, as a publicist, he makes
a printing press in his house near Paris,
a place called Passy, and he prints the
Declaration of Independence,
and all the great
documents coming out of America.
Of course he's renowned as a scientist,
'cause the French had
been the first people
to do his lightning rod experiments,
so they love him in
France, and he's kind of,
he has, you know, Deborah Read has died
by this point, so even as he's in his 70s,
he has two famous girlfriends, mistresses
in Paris, and he writes wonderful poetry
and bagatelles and stories to them.
So he is a great bon vivant in Paris.
Voiceover: So he's a bit of a Parisian.
Voiceover: Very much of a Parisian,
and drinks wonderful amounts of port.
John Adams also has to come
to Paris at a certain point.
John Adams is very much the Puritan.
And even though they
had worked together for
many years, they didn't
really like each other.
And John Adams was appalled at Franklin
having two girlfriends,
and getting up late
in the morning, and drinking a lot of port
and brandy, but it is Franklin who is able
to get the French in on our side, and then
the triumph in Paris is
called the Treaty of Paris,
when the war is winding
down, and Benjamin Franklin
is able to negotiate
the treaty with Britain
to end the American
Revolution and give the
U. S. its independence,
and it ends the war,
and Franklin is able to
do it working with the
French, sometimes behind
the back of the French,
a very wily diplomat,
and at that point they've
kicked John Adams out because they know...
Voiceover: They didn't like him.
Voiceover: Ben Franklin's
the guy who can make
this complicated piece happen.
Voiceover: And they liked him more.
Voiceover: Oh yeah,
(laughing) he was definitely,
if you had to choose who are you gonna
spend the evening with
in Paris, you'd pick
Ben Franklin over John Adams, even though
we have to give John
Adams [unintelligible]
for being a very, very important patriot.
Voiceover: And this is
the big picture, this is
the one something that
was surprising to me,
is that Benjamin Franklin,
who is one of our
larger than life founding
fathers, his role
was not to pick up a musket, his role was
for the second half of his
life, he was in Europe,
he was in London, he
was in Paris, and he was
really there to represent
the country and to
negotiate with both England, as kind of an
adversary, or eventually an adversary,
and with Paris, as an ally.
Voiceover: And we would
not really have won
the Revolution without his diplomacy,
because it's the French who send most of
the gunpowder we used,
most of the troops used,
it's Vergennes, the French
foreign minister who helps
send a navy, so that at Yorktown, when
George Washington wins the battle, that
pretty much ends the Revolution because
the French navy is there supporting him.
So all of these things work,
and finally, near the end,
in 1885, I think, as he's just about to
turn 80, he comes back
for the last few years
of his life, gets involved in the
Constitutional Convention, and
becomes a great elder statesman.
Voiceover: Fascinating.